tu serais Mme Dutton il semblerait que nous soyons
voisins j'ai acquis le Stratford
Ranch
eh bien c'est la pierre jaune et tu
n'as aucun droit ici
Jacob tu ne peux pas commencer une gamme gamme de guerre les
guerres ont déjà commencé
atterrissons tu veux
Je veux toute la vallée
peut-être qu'on leur livre ce combat ou ça
vient nous
les hommes tuons vite avec une balle pour un nœud coulant
avec leur combat est avec moi et je tue
beaucoup plus lentement
tu es un chasseur tu es célèbre
dis au monde ce qui se passe  quand ils
me croiseront, la
cupidité sera la chose qui nous tuera
tous
l'eau de pluie
vient avec moi
tu sais que Dieu Jacob ne le fait pas [
Applaudissements]
tu attaque ma famille ça va être la
dernière chose que tu feras